everything in your life will change when
you realize that you do not want an easy
life stop praying for easy stop praying
for convenience you don't want it
because you don't want to photocopy your
life every single day over and over and
over and over again you want variety you
want change you want something different
but with that variety comes uncertainty
comes pain comes challenges and from
that pain comes purpose ultimately your
purpose comes from your pain and the
more pain you go through the more
challenges you take on the more you
stretch yourself in your comfort zone
the more you're going to be able to
reach down and help somebody come up to
your level as well